Toby is a farmer.
He plants 12 rows of
carrots in a field.
Each row has 6 carrots.
How many carrots did Toby plant?
So let's try to
visualize this thing.
So they tell us each
row has 6 carrots.
So let's try to visualize a row.
So that's 1 carrot,
that's 2 carrots, that's
3 carrots, that's 4
carrots, that's 5 carrots,
and that's 6 carrots.
And I can even do,
just so it looks
nice, the little leafy
part of the carrots.
So we can visualize
these as carrots.
So that's 1 row of carrots.
They tell us each
row has 6 carrots.
Now, there're 12 of these.
He plants 12 rows of carrots.
Let me see if I can
copy and paste this.
So copy and paste.
So that's 2 rows.
I want to make sure
I have enough space.
2 rows.
That's 3 rows.
That's 4 rows.
This is 5 rows.
This is 6 rows.
And actually, I can just copy
and paste the whole thing.
This is 6 rows.
I just need to double
that to get to 12 rows.
So let me do that.
So copy and paste.
There you go.
So there's 12 rows
right over here.
And let's number this.
So they tell us each row has
6 carrots-- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
They tell us he
plants a total of 12
rows-- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
How many carrots did Toby plant?
Well, you could do
this exercise and then
try to count all
of these carrots.
But that seems a
little bit crazy.
These are already
a lot of carrots.
And especially if these
were even larger numbers,
it would take you
forever to count it.
Luckily for us, we have
multiplication as a tool
that we can use.
So if you have 12 rows and
each of those rows have 6,
this is really 12 times 6.
You're going to have 12 rows.
In each of those,
you have 6 carrots.
So you could say you
have 6 carrots 12 times.
So it's going to be 12 times 6.
If you remember your
multiplication tables up to 12,
you'll remember that
12 times 6 is 72.
So he has 72 carrots.
Even if you only remember--
well, I'll just leave it there.
If you remember your
multiplication--
which you should, because that
is one of the things in life
that will have long-lasting
benefits-- it's 72 carrots.